we're going to have two talks we have
half an hour break we have another two
talks we afterwards have our open
discussion 12 to 12:30 and it's
not notice also we have from 2 to three
we have eight of N9 seven talks that are
Maxim 8 minutes long so here is
um and so on so we have seven talks
actually have eight minutes two to three
for those who participate in the
reception tonight at 4:15 the bell will
ring please start marching because at
4:3 please check the email with the
exact it's up the
hill that's the
Bell so when you're up there on the
white board and you hear some bell then
you know it is time to
start you should just lead everybody and
just go
I everybody speaks German
so okay great so we started our first
talk
come thank
you
very
um so yeah I'm going to talk about Rings
sorry not semi Rings although you know
on my slides I will point out sometimes
you know that this also works for semi
Rings you know and usually everything
works for same Rings uh except for the
ultimate purpose for which I'm
developing this right
um so so why do I want
rings so I mean this has come out of
projects uh that I've been working on
where we wanted to compile queries and
uh where we really suffered from having
so many different case distinctions when
skl was really very messy language to us
and I tried to clean this
up um and uh generally speaking of
course you know nowadays if data science
people have come up with lots and lots
of calculi and so on for for numeric
computations I'm going to talk about my
thing which is in this you you know case
quite old already um so um you know uh
relation calcus and algebra terrible for
numeric computations right it starts
with that you know Union is not even an
operation right um cly not a total
operation because there's certainly
pairs of relations that you could that
you're not allowed to un together right
um so we don't have a semi ring we
certainly don't have an algebra cical
algebra yes but not an algebra um
aggregations and afterthought certainly
in these core languages have we've been
studying most right and you know one
very experienced senior um colleague of
mine once told me about undergrads you
know that no matter what we do they will
never understand Universal agregation uh
Universal quantification right so it's
it's hopeless and in my experience
having graded millions of database exams
you know um I think this is true right
and people you know when you give them
some Universal Property usually if they
manage at all to realize that there's
something to be done here that is is not
just existential right uh they will do
something like doing accounting qu right
I've dumbed this down you know of course
this would usually qualified in some way
right but rather than saying you know
you know is it true that all you know
people understand for all right you ask
you count the guys who understand for
all and you count the people and you
compare that right and that's what
people do right um so uh in a sense
right and of course saying this as
somebody who has you know you know
gotten a job basically basically on
based on working with logic you know
maybe I feel like a traitor to you but
uh you know um quantification is
actually not that important to most
people in who use these languages but
aggregation is okay and there's things I
would like to do and for which I need
rings as well particular I would like to
be able to uh you know Express finite
differencing elegantly right I would
call this differentiation sometimes
because it's easier to say right and
this is key to many things we did a lot
of incremental view maintenance work but
you need this in other context as well I
mean one thing that we have said heard a
lot about is seminar vation with dat log
of course that's incremental compation
but there's all kinds of different
versions of things like online and
streaming Etc that need this and even
just for you know expressing you know
many you know core query operat
algorithms you know kind of applying it
Delta you know is is an important thing
right and right now if you try to figure
out how to do this for SQL without any
kind of clean up you know this is a very
messy task and that's why you know when
I I started working on this I don't
think that people have been working on
very large fragments of SQL to do things
like incremental view
maintenance so uh here's a key Tool uh
monoid semi rings Rings right so let's
assume we've got a semi- ring or ring a
and a mono h g okay and I'm defining you
know finite support functions that means
functions right where only fin met
elements M to something else than zero
right the zero of uh the semi ring a
okay and I Define the operations in this
way so I've got these functions X you
know maps to Alpha of X you know is one
of them you know Alpha and the sum of
two such things is just you know the
pair wise sum here right the important
thing the multiplication is the
convolution product
okay um and this is where a mon plays
off right we're basically saying you
know uh for for an X right its value is
going to be you know for the product you
know but split up in all ways that they
multiply up to X right gets y's and Zs
of G right and you know sum up the
products of these Alpha of of Y and beta
of of Z okay and it's very straight for
to define a z and one such we've got
this got a semi- ring and a ring if a is
a ring okay we call this a mono semi
ring or ring right and if it's
cumulative it's also an algebra so it's
a mon
algebra um so uh one thing that worth
observing although it's very obvious if
you just take the uh the plus operation
of this uh of such a mon ring and you
add some obvious killer product so you
can multiply in so to say the uh the uh
elements of of of the of the Ring right
then you've got a pre module on on G
okay and with this it's actually very
easy to prove the the following thing
right um so think of characteristic
functions for every element of the
monoid right um I have got a function
that basically you know um uh maps to
Value one for for G and and to Z for
everything else right and we say that
some operation we're going to talk about
operations for multiplication here you
know over in this case the the the the
Ring of of integers right is
conservative over uh over the
multiplication inside the monoid right
if on these characteristic functions
it's actually just this product okay and
my opinion that's what you always want
otherwise would be very weird okay and
if you make this assumption there is
actually just one way to build a product
to get a ring given the addition
operation on such functions okay and
that's this convolution product Christ
it might be just me but I don't
understand this uh last condition the
conservativity can you explain again
right so um I've got the the the items
of elements of the monoid right uh
remember my my uh my monoid ring the
elements are functions right yeah and
there are special elements that look
like these characteristic functions
right okay and now I'm talking about
possible multiplication operations for
for my monoid ring right I already
showed you one but I want to kind of
justify it right so let's not
constrained yet right let's say what
could M multiplication function could I
build and let's just assume that I want
to look at those that satisfy this
property right you know that the product
in my in my monoid ring um of the C
functions of G and H is the
characteristic function of G * H in the
in the
monoid okay yeah um we will later
actually use tles for these elements of
this monoid right and then this is very
obvious that that's what you want it
would be very weird otherwise okay and
with this and the fact that you've got
these modules you can very easily prove
that there is is just one way namely
this convolution product to build a ring
okay yes sorry I missed something on the
previous slide you you back the
multiplicative unit
here
um confused so why does it
have
support well it is nonzero only on the
one element of G
right so it has fin support is only one
non zero element so yeah
okay uh I know the notation bad
right okay good so um this is also all
very basic you know algebra stuff for
the moment right um and now let's apply
this to databases right so um we're
going to build a monitoring of relations
right so what I'm going remember one
thing I want to achieve is that un is a
total operation you might say not a big
deal why do make such a fuss of it
because I would otherwise be Gil of case
distinctions when we do incremental view
indion for example where we've got
Deltas where un is a is something that
is applied in very in many different and
weird ways including you know doing
differences right um so so record
conceptually is a tle with scheme of its
own right so a relation in my context
could have records tles of different
schemas right it's a set of tles and
each tle has its own schema right it's a
kind of partial function mapping column
names to data values right and with talk
about we call this this T is the set of
all records that I can build right give
them a uh you know a vocabulary of uh
column names and um a domain of data
values right so we call this generaliz
mul generalized multi set relation you
know a finite support function from tles
to elements of our semi ring or ring
okay and here's an example right so you
see as two tles that have you know
weight value whatever R1 R2 right and
this one is actually kind of a unary tle
and this is a binary tle
right and I've just bunched them
together and because they have their own
schema so to say you know there's no
problem with doing that yeah it's just
kind of polymorphic so to say these
relations and um here is my monut ring
of relations again and I'm sorry I'm
basically very done here because I'm
showing you the same stuff again here
just I filled in now this concrete you
know um structure here right so the
monoid is now these these tles right and
the operation the multiplication
operation of the monoid is putting them
into Singleton relations and joining
them with natural join
okay and you again have the convolution
product etc etc right everything else
you know the one element you have got
got these nuller tles these empty tles
as so to say the smallest possible tles
right and of course joining them in
doesn't change the thing it's important
so to say right you join this in yes so
if if if you're just joining two
indidual t is not set of Toppers what
happens if they don't join if they
disagree on the common attribut what is
the result of the joint well we're not
Computing this this is not how the join
works the only way we actually kind of
using this mon operation is here and if
it doesn't match we're not going to use
these Yen's right yeah are you using a
commutative joint this joint is
commutative right this this
multiplication operation is commutative
right and of course because we have a
ring here we also have a a a minus
operation uh to the plus right so
example and I'm just showing you this
again for reference right suppose I've
got these three generalized mod set
relations right let's take S&T and at
them together right um so um well I can
these two go together so I get you know
for C I get S Plus T1 for BC I get T2
right and now the multiplication right
the thing is now um I have to look for
every tle here right that I want to
construct and conceptually this is a
very indirect thing I have to think all
possible tles Right but there will be
only you know finally many that have
nonzero weight given that the input if
so right I have to con see all ways of
constructing these tles right so in the
interesting case here is this thing um
A2 BC which I can construct in two ways
by joining so to say or multiplying r
with S Plus T right because um this
thing joins with this no contradiction
it also joins with this of course if
this was B prime a different value would
not join right and for that reason I get
you know this sum here right sorry yeah
why did uh joined with the first row of
S Plus T um it's in this case it's like
a a rational product operation right
okay don't overlap in schema it's like a
natural join obiously yeah it's a
natural join right so how should we read
the missing entry so under under B
there's only one B so so you could talk
about null vales I don't think of them
as n Val it's probably we not Kean to
think of null values right I think of
them as that these are not tles but
records they have their own schema okay
so it's polymorphic each of these things
is an object you know each each of these
records that knows its schema and it's
its local domain right okay so this stle
says Ah I'm I'm a unit dou on C and this
D says I'm a biner dou on B and C
okay and why am I doing this obviously
that I can unit together anything right
so I've got a total operation I can the
ring without having weird exceptions and
and and weird things to say about it
right yeah sorry for nping but you do
want to have a monoid structure on the
set of tles yeah what is a binary
operation that has to be defined for any
pairs of elements the yeah I I that's
that's this um it's it's the um natural
joint on Singletons yeah but the natural
joint is not always
defined um so I understand you can
Define the comp solution but I don't
think you can Define the basic oper
monoid operation or at least I don't
understand how you define it yeah um so
um yeah I mean I have in the full thing
there's some kind of version of a fail
and I've build a monitor around it but I
I wanted to leave this out here good
thanks okay s sorry about that you know
because I really don't need it for
anything else yeah so um and there is a
semantic defici data where you see these
things but I will go all this quickly
because otherwise it's going to be very
boring for
everybody um
okay so uh but yes very good point sorry
about being you know trying to brush
this under the rock um right so um yeah
so this thing is a communative ring one
of course and I've shown you this thing
already it has this minus operation and
it's also if you take take it for the
the whole numbers right the integers as
as as the ring it's the smallest ring
right um such that uh all relations in
set of back are elements right and plus
and and multiplication generaliz unit
and natural join right so in particular
if you apply this stuff you know to just
normal relations you know this is
exactly unit and this is exactly the
natural
joint
okay so this is not arbitrary but that's
the natural thing to do right so this
this is something that is exactly un
natural joint normal relations multi set
relations you know back semantics but
also sets you like you know but it also
works for these things that I get by
basically putting
items together that are you know have
different schema you
know okay and it doesn't do more than
that it just does exactly
this what I think I running out of time
okay um yeah so um well you can build
pooms you can think distinguish Elements
which are variables and which are
constant relations of course and um you
can uh talk about deltas right just
using this stivity right um this maybe
looks hard to read but just the
multiplication right I mean suppose I've
got some some general mation and it's
Delta times some other plus is Delta
minus the old version right I just you
know apply theity and I get these things
right okay and one thing that is worth
mentioning here is that um that uh you
can talk about the degree right so if
you have got kind of two variables here
you know um it has degree two and the
delta always has degree one less unless
it become becomes zero right that's
important for this differentiation here
you can you know can basically
differentiate this these things as many
times as you like but every time the deg
degree goes down by one
okay okay um so one thing that I need
next is uh a generalization of these
things these are again rings but they're
not going to be communative anymore
right they allow me to do sideway
binding passing okay and that allows me
to basically have conditions which are
by themselves not finite support
okay um so that would be kind of
infinite tables that I can join in so to
say right um and um so so basically what
I'm going to have is you know before
that I had these things that are
functions from tles to to uh to uh ring
elements now I've got functions from
tles to tles ring elements think this is
just a current form but I think this
this first thing is going to be the
bound variables the input variables and
that's these are those that I can
compute the output variables right and
given this this is again finite support
right and ultimately can prove in some
way other essentially there's again only
one way to build this right and what it
basically does is that's the interesting
part looks kind of ugly right that you
can basically pass the output variables
of one relation as input variables of
the other right you know and otherwise
it's again this convolution this is
again a ring you know um theity proof is
kind of cute also very very easy right
and this is something you can now use to
kind of do things like you know sideways
binding Bing like in relation cus we can
talk about safe queries Etc okay um
sorry Kristoff um why couldn't we get a
uh inverse here uh what no no we can't
get an inverse okay you're in a semi-
ring for some reason all of a sudden no
I always I wanted to be as Channel as
possible I always talk about Sam ring
and but it also works for Rings you know
because they are also SEI Rings sorry I
I if I didn't go this consistently no I
know I I do I say yeah no this is um
yeah okay in the title I should have to
put this same me again in parenthesis
sorry yeah um yeah so I can do that and
since since I'm running out of time I
want to speed up a bit we have to define
a language right um and the important
thing about this language is that it
basically does all the interesting stuff
of of of of SQL you know there is of
course ugly stuff you know that maybe
you know null values we don't look
particularly in in out the joins and
stuff like that right but it can do all
the aggregations and it can do Universal
quantification in particular right so we
have these operations of the ring that
we already have seen right we've got
some ring elements relations Atomic
relations but also functions like
arithmetic functions and so on and we
can take variables you know that we have
basically you know you know fetched you
know just like in racial calculus and
basically maybe uh if they numerical
kind of make them part of something that
we sum up we've got conditions okay and
um there's semantics and it's horrible
and I'm just going to show you that U
that so this is the stuff that we have
already seen before summation right is
kind of a generalization of addition of
of course right and the important thing
is that they're basically saying you
know um if I've got some variable right
um some some tle here right this sum is
basically over y that I can multiply in
such I get y again right and as a
consequence what this means is um that
um this is not like just like a
projection that counts the copies right
it doesn't just compute uh tles of maybe
you know where some variables have been
removed but also these where the VAR are
still in there right and if you don't
want them you know you just don't you
know quer them further later on and
actually this is the only way to do this
so you get a ring right some of this
stuff it's impossible to read right now
right but it was actually quite tricky
in many cases again you can argue that
this is the only way to do this okay um
so we have conditions right uh we also
have something called lifting but you
can basically take uh you know some
query right and take the kind of stuff
that is basically this this multiplicity
right the the ring stuff and lift it
again and put it into a as a data value
into into a column right um and
um here's an example right um and I'm
since I don't have the time I'm not
going to go for this right we can do
Deltas for all of them again the ugly
thing is the Delta for the condition
because that basically just says in
general Right add the new version of
everything and subtract the old version
right it's not a good nice efficient
Delta on the other hand you know if this
Alpha
doesn't contain the subquery right you
know no relational atoms right then this
the Delta is zero okay so in many case
if you don't have nested queries of
complex structure this is actually easy
okay and um we can Define degrees Again
by every you know the degree of the
Delta is always one less or zero right
than the the degree of the of the input
query
okay so with that we've done something
that I want to quickly talk about which
is this what you call recursive inter
incremental view maintenance right so
you've got this kind of difference
operation right and you're talking about
some in this case i' simplified this and
basically look look like an integer
right talking with the successor element
in the case of relations this is you
know the relation and the relation plus
one toule of your choice right so I I
want to simplify to kind of illustrate
the idea here right what you can do is
the following right suppose you've got
some polinomial that's a query right you
can talk it's it's differences you can
compute those according to the rules
that we have okay at some point the
difference here is zero right what you
can do is you know as you go and you
know adds to X some values right you
know you can compute this thing right
but you can always you know compute this
new thing as the old version plus the
Delta obviously right you can do this
for the entire table right you can
memorize the whole thing right so this
thing is this thing and that thing or
this thing is this thing and that thing
right and um the thing is we can compute
incrementally
values for this function without any
multiplications there just additions and
memorization right and the thing is this
of course a bit more notation you can do
for our quer language as well that means
you get rid of the joints there are no
joints in this thing but you memorize
multiple levels you know of Deltas right
if you can afford this you get rid of
the
joints
okay um I have some
um
example in this case I wrote write it
like SQL because there is a direct
mapping to our language right and um you
can basically take such a query and this
is a very fast animation because I know
I'm going to run another time um um and
um I'm basically doing what we do here
you know on this example of SQL right I
want to Compu Delta for this sare Q
right so this is a tpch like schema
right so I've got orders and line items
right and I'm asking for the uh the sum
of the prices times exchange rates so
convert it to one currency right of
orders join of line items right um this
is this case just a one value is a Zero
Dimensional quer so to say there's no
group I in this case but this also works
for group eyes Okay and the degree is
two because I've got two relational
variables here that I'm joining together
so I want to compute the Delta as I for
now insert a single tle in our work we
have built a system we can also do batch
updating and so on it's more complicated
I'm not covering it here but in this
case we're talking about inserting we
could also talk about deleting single
tles now you know in this case for in
inserting an order tle right so um so I
can talk can express and I've just
written all of this in in in in in in in
this this language here or in an SQL um
you know my my Delta and I can can start
optimizing this right so this is the
query but I'm going to insert now a
Singleton you know that's the Delta into
this o and now I'm going to simplify
this is just a compilation step where I
simplify things right so I can pull this
out this is just um associativity
right and at some point I'm done and
I've got a query that in this case just
degree one not degree two anymore and
I'm going to materialize this and it's a
gr I now for X order key right and I'm
materializing this and we have to Inc
that one as well right so I give this a
name um and I'm going to take this
Square again and I increment main it of
course for line item because order
orders don't exist here I can simplify
and I get for all
this um some in insert triggers I can do
this for delete triggers as well okay
and in this case you know um there are
no joints all these multiplications are
on scalers right um and um so this is
kind of constant time updates right for
this thing for this right and um so in
general we have some combination
techniques here where we basically built
these triggers you know this looks bit
like C this this thing we call this NC
zal C because we can prove that um
everything you know the data complexity
after compilation is in NC Z okay and
remember nc0 are you know constant dep
circuits you know of bounded Fanning
right um and they have been separated
from a z which is the complexity class
that we best you know know for for for
for relational algebra right so we
actually have a complexity sitation that
actually is known to be strictly smaller
than AC this is not a complex detic
assumption this is one of the case we
actually have separated the classes
right and the incremental computation is
possible n z why it takes us a z or if
you've got you know um aggregation even
something slightly bigger than that um
TC Z you know for the non-rental version
right so there a kind of complexity
theorem here as
well and uh yeah we've built a system
around called DB TOA it still exists um
you can download it and use it and play
with it there's a lot more in that
system a lot of work went into the
compilation into like doing this thing
on a large scale and efficiently and you
know for large quer language um but yeah
that's that's what we've done here
Christ I recommend that you ask for a
show of hands for how many people have
used theb toaster because I have pretty
sure many people one one oh wow many
more that's nice thank you thank you
it's
good probably all all the users are in
the
room no actually this is not true
because we actually got a lot of
requests and so on yeah but U
unfortunately never mind went beyond
just some G
project a lot of cod though question um
uh a cyclic schemas only in essence no
uh no restriction of that kind at
all okay I don't understand how you
disambiguate a cyclic schema this so you
have to understand one thing right you
know this
grants Yogo ear eating algorithm for
proving that something is a cyclic right
you take a a hypergraph and you start
ear away according to rules those that
are very loose at the at the boundaries
right the thing is in our technique you
know when I when I um do this
compilation and every time I basically
replace you know a relation um by by
this kind of top you know by this single
topple thing right this is the stuff
that I'm filling in and then I'm
starting to kind of simplify right you
know um I'm basically removing a
hyperedge but this is not restricted to
as ones you just remove hyper edges you
know and the CR gets smaller and smaller
right there is nothing special that we
exploit for ecity here it doesn't
care okay yes I'm sorry do I decide no
I'm done with my talk I'm I'm already
answering questions is this okay or
should I
[Applause]
say like one slide about open open
things that because 10 like the next
steps or any
conclusion just uh so so this is a
question now yeah okay because there
other people okay yeah so um well look
the thing is you know um we spent a lot
of time on this right um building this
thing and we built lots of prototypes
and we sometimes rote it you know using
new languages and so on right um and um
you know we published this um at
different times you know we were
thinking about doing a startup you know
there was po I did this stuff initially
with janif uh we wanted to Startup then
um didn't happen when he went to
Academia and I was and later there was
Oliver that many of you know and have
worked with and before I think about
doing a startup and it never happened
because it's just a two of us you know
and um and um you know um at some point
you know we all kind of burned out with
this project right um so um no I think
there's no great I mean you know the
kind of cleanup version of of some
things that I talked about today it's
actually not published it's just a
technical report maybe one more thing to
do is publish this but I'm not sure if
anybody still wants it because it's like
10 years old and people have already
moved on and you know and basically have
to kind of say oh but this is worth
publishing because it actually happened
before all these other people have done
something very similar right but I mean
dbto studies is a benchmark for I mean
people compare whatever approach they
take to incal view Benchmark for the
students that work on it and now have
academic careers and I only in in the
business of like just saying how bad
this is how much better their thing is
you do now
right with franker and and this I didn't
bring up the to but it came out because
they were comparing I me Frank at least
was comparing what the materialized iio
how did compar you know I had I never
had the energy to kind of really do the
comparison myself right of course Frank
MC's work is beautiful and um it is a
lot more General right you can do this
for pretty much anything right but you
know all the stuff that we can do you
know since we do a lot of static stuff
right we in principle can be better more
efficient yeah
yeah but I I would say I don't think you
can get a paper accepted in Sigma or VB
on incremental anything without
comparing to the that's the way it
should be although I'm not a reviewer
you
[Laughter]
know it's a system to be okay good but I
think you want I'm sorry you you you
have you ra yeah this question might be
too half big so maybe we'll take it
offline but I I was trying to understand
when you're aving the joint by
maintaining that memo table yeah what's
the space-time tradeoff there like can
you bound how big that table gets and
what the costs are of moving that data
in and out to work on
it no no it can be quite bad so there's
this thing the re algorithm from like
expert systems this net thing it remind
me a little bit of this but I don't know
if you've looked at that or if it's
related at all the W um I'm honestly not
not not sure but if I can yeah I mean
maybe I I forgot because this were like
13 years ago that the
last but yeah I mean so the thing is um
uh usually right um these uh these
auxiliary views right have um you know
they have this lower degree right and
usually this is also reflected in the
kind of number of relations that join
together right so we can usually assume
it's of course a question of which which
cons you have to keep you know and not
project way that these things are
smaller right but it's still costly in
general and there's tricks you have done
this in dbos there some tradeoffs where
you basically decide not to material
certain things and do it in several
steps this is something we' have done
absolutely right um and um you know
there is a lot of things I didn't say
because it's unless you want to build
this it's it's it's it's doesn't matter
to you but it was we had a lot spend a
lot of time on it for example this
lifting operation right that takes
basically something that is a
multiplicity right this in this kind of
you know uh you know multiplicity domain
and lifts and put back into the into the
data vales in the table and so on to
this efficiently right is is was very
complex the optimization
operations techniques for that and so on
right and there particular there
sometimes a trade of to where we
actually we don't materialize this thing
yeah so please please keep your
questions uh we have here this
discussion let's thank
again